Bobby had access lining up to play Ken's
but it didn't work out for everyone for
a surprising reason who backed away from
the past and why it's likely not a huge
surprise that's when it was announced
that Oscar nominated writer director
Greta Gerwig was making a Barbie movie
actors across Hollywood wanted to get
involved right away Vanity Fair spoke to
two of the movie's casting directors
Lucy Bevin and Alison Jones to dig
deeper into how the county-coated fierce
feminist film managed to score its
star-studded lineup as it turns out we
missed out on three potential cans but
when Yang Dan Levy and Ben Platt all
wanted to play Ken's butts couldn't make
it work due to covid-19 restrictions and
plays during filming what do I have to
do you have to go to the real world
while Bobby was in production the entire
cast had to commit to staying in London
for the entirety of the shoot due to
strict covid-19 protocols and yang Levy
and Platt couldn't make the commitment
for a variety of reasons it's easy
enough to guess why Yang is a cast
member on Saturday Night Live Dan heavy
just briefly worked on the idle and
Platt is currently starring in parade on
Broadway as well as a new film Theater
Camp still the casting directors said
that those actors were quite upset that
they couldn't make it work Jones told
Vanity Fair they were I'm not kidding
and really bummed they couldn't do it
according to the vanity fairpiece Kim
wasn't the only part in Barbie being
fought over in Hollywood incredibly the
role of Alan Ken's buddy who in dull
form fits into all of Ken's same clothes
was a hot ticket as well and at first
Jonathan Graf known for projects like
mind Hunter looking and Frozen really
really wanted to play the amorphous blob
known as Alan unfortunately for graph he
suffered the same fate as the others
Jones isn't specific about whether or
not Groff was simply auditioning himself
for the part or actually in talks
further down the line but she does say
that eventually Gruff reached out and
said he couldn't make London work the
role of Alan ultimately went to Scott
Pilgrim himself Michael Sarah and the
Lord due respect to Graf Sarah couldn't
be more perfect in the role described by
vulture as Jen Cheney as quote A vibe of
having no vibe counts as a Vibe Alan is
just kind of there Sarah a master of
quiet deadpan completely Nails the part
you humans we're fine and Ellen so how
did Bevin and Jones settle on the Kens
and Barbies who ended up in the movie
when it came to the Kens Bevin said they
were definitely really different but
they had to feel like a cohesive group
you wanted to cast people who are really
going to get on and be great and enjoy
it based on the end result it seems like
that's exactly what happened Barbie is a
film that's even in its most emotional
moments overflows with uninhibited Joy
unsurprisingly Gerwig was also closely
involved in casting Bevin said she
showed the casting director's old
illustrations of classic Barbie and
kendalls to narrow down a certain look
but the personality was still Paramount
Bevin said she really wanted to get to
know them as people that was very
important to her on the key Barbie and
Ken rolls she got a very good idea of
what an actor was like from talking to
them here's the good news Marvel simu
Liu really really wanted to pass in the
movie and he ended up playing the main
Nemesis and eventual Ally to Gosling's
main can I'll beat you off with you any
day Ken Barbie is in theater now